this is always a difficult and deeply
saddening task for soo-chang land
funded by donations from an American aid
organization sue supports parents
looking for their children who have
simply disappeared
stolen kidnapped and sold parents like
shop owner Chang and his wife are
desperate Chang went to pick up his
five-year-old daughter from school he
was a bit late and she was no longer
there that was nine years ago
since then the couple have spent every
free minute searching for their daughter
they've hung up posters and distributed
leaflets spending all their money
they've stayed even though the shop
isn't doing well hoping their daughter
might remember it and find her way back
there someday my husband and I will
never give up we'll keep looking for her
and one day we'll find her we'll never
give up no matter how hard and bitter it
is our life is agonizing the local
police don't like taking on cases like
this because they cost a lot of time and
money and are rarely successful that
makes their case records look bad they
now consider Cheng and his wife as
troublemakers instead of helping them
they try to suppress them when I tried
to look for my daughter in a nearby town
the police demolished my car that
doesn't want me to look for my child
publicly and they tried to tear down my
posters they say our society is very
stable and my actions destabilize it the
official figure is 10,000 children
kidnapped each year but the unofficial
number is probably much higher other
estimates put the figure as high as
70,000 the children are then sold in
villages like this
sue helps women here look for their
natural parents human traffickers
brought Xiao Guang Yan here when she was
7 to a family with three sons
she was purchased to be a wife for the
youngest son I missed my parents
dreadfully but I didn't have the courage
to call out for them
I kept their names in my heart and
always thought of them shell grew up
almost like an adopted daughter many
parents in rural areas prefer to have
sons but because of China's stringent
birth control laws there are now too few
women even as a child she all knew she
would be expected to marry her new
brother they don't usually send the
children they've bought to school few of
them can read or write the new families
put pressure on them to prevent them
from looking for their real parents
they're afraid they might return to them
but they've purchased the girls in order
to later marry their sons she'll had to
submit to her fate she's now been
married to who Han Lee Anne for 20 years
and they have three children one
daughter is attending University
but she never let go of her past she
wanted to know where she came from and
who her birth parents were by chance she
heard about the American aid
organization and got to know suchan lon
the Chinese government gives its
citizens know help with searches like
these but Shou actually found her
parents via Sue's work when they
reunited the parents put a red sash over
their lost daughter's shoulder since
then she's visited them on a regular
basis Shell's husband supported her
search not many men would do that
because the subject remains to boo and
even he doesn't like to talk about how
it was back then when he had to marry
his sister at first it felt strange but
then we got used to it after a year or
two hadn't they ever wanted to choose
their own partners back then it was very
conservative here it wasn't an option
she´ll story isn't an isolated case
thousands of girls in China who've been
sold are looking for their parents
usually secretly
against the will of their husbands su
Chun lands aid organization fund
searches and the construction of a DNA
databank parents and children looking
for each other submit DNA samples many
see that is the only way to find each
other again because the government has
failed them so far together with the
parents of stolen children sue is even
publicizing the problem that's risky
because campaigns like this are
forbidden in China the police have
frequently detained her for disturbing
the peace but this time everything goes
well
I don't think parents should ever give
up hope
and they have to become active
themselves in addition we need more
involvement from civil society and of
course the government has to make more
of an effort to help our work instead of
hindering it sue gets a lot of
encouragement from passersby private
individuals commit themselves to her
cause that's new in China where the
government usually regulates everything
but more and more people in this country
see themselves as citizens and demand
their rights and parents of missing
children in particular would like the
government to help them in their search